[Musica]
[Applauso]
vi siete mai chiesti se l'orologio e in
tutte le sue forme analogiche o digitali
influenza la vostra produttività In
altre parole Secondo voi sapere l'ora
tante volte al giorno aumenta la vostra
produttività la diminuisce e la lascia
invariata
ricevere una risposta anche solo mentale
alla domanda che ore sono più volte al
giorno a tre effetti immediati sulla
nostra produttività Il primo è
un'interruzione dello stato di
concentrazione Noi siamo impegnati in
un'attività veniamo a sapere l'ora e tac
questo è sufficiente interrompere il
nostro flusso di idee e la nostra
concentrazione è l'equivalente dice
c'era uno schiaffo mentre stiamo
sognando Gloria Mark esperta nello
studio della frammentazione
dell'attenzione ha dimostrato che è una
piccola distrazione anche di una
frazione di secondo proprio come
ricevere allora
può prolungare un compito mediamente dai
5 ai 30 minuti Se venite disturbati da
un orologio ogni 10 minuti riuscite a
fare un calcolo di quanto tempo perdete
in un giorno
moltiplicate per un anno
il secondo effetto è creare una distonia
corpo mente
la mente quando viene a sapere l'ora
rispondi in automatico Alla domanda Cosa
c'è dopo
è mezzogiorno sono a pranzo con un
cliente guardiamo l'ora e ci viene in
mente una riunione che avremo nel
pomeriggio Ecco che con il corpo Noi
siamo ancora lì a pranzo con il cliente
ma con la mente siamo già alla riunione
del pomeriggio il problema è che nessuna
attività può essere realmente intensa e
produttiva se viene vissuta con questa
distonia se non viene vissuta con la
vostra massima presenza
Date un'occhiata a questa slide
avete riconosciuto qualcuno mi viene in
mente qualcuno
andiamo alla terza il terzo effetto
facilitare la procrastinazione
allontanarvi dalle attività impegnative
sapere l'ora crea un collegamento un
riferimento automatico
rispetto a quanto sta durando una certa
attività
sono le 14 già 20 minuti che sto
ascoltando belzzani Ok quando siete
immersi in un'attività che richiede una
certa forza di volontà per essere
portata fino in fondo come ad esempio
che ne so guardare un corso di
formazione a leggere un libro scrivere
un articolo
avere un'indicazione che avete già
investito del tempo in quell'attività
può essere sufficiente ad autorizzarvi a
fare uno stacco
ora
la mente vi è come se facesse un reset
Come fa un PC e servisse nuova forza di
volontà e nuova energia per ricominciare
spesso non ne siamo provvisti E quindi
cosa facciamo
seguiamo un impulso di solito mangiare
bere qualcosa
leggo le mail guardo che mi ha scritto
su Facebook risultato sempre lo stesso
allunghiamo i tempi di esecuzione di
compiti e
prolunghiamo le attività impegnative ce
le dimentichiamo
calo della produttività
da queste informazioni verrebbe da
pensare che l'orologio non sia poi uno
strumento così utile alla produttività
Se volessimo andare all'origine di
questo atteggiamento morboso nei
confronti dell'orologio non solo
potremmo identificare una data precisa
ma anche preciso colpevole con tanto di
nome e cognome lo volete conoscere
nel 18 novembre del 1883 un uomo fermò
il tempo per circa 4 minuti
quest'uomo risponde al nome di James
hamplet responsabile dell'orologio
elettrico delle stazioni ferroviarie
della Western Union Stati Uniti
all'epoca non c'era uno standard orario
univoco Quindi tutte le stazioni
ferroviarie degli Stati Uniti dovete
pensare che c'erano circa 70 modi
diversi per rispondere alla
semplicissima domanda Che ore sono
fermò l'orologio per tre minuti e 58
secondi con il preciso intento di creare
un orario univoco e dare così una nuova
definizione al concetto di adesso che
fino ad allora era completamente
soggettivo da questo fatto storico
cambiarono molte cose i primi a subire
nelle conseguenze furono i poveri
commercianti vedete i commercianti qui
affari dipendevano dai prezzi
all'ingrosso Furono costretti a guardare
con sempre più regolarità le
fluttuazioni dei prezzi e questo
continuare a maneggiare a monitorare
queste fluttuazioni le rendeva più
frequenti creando un circolo vizioso che
da lì in poi sarebbe andato sempre a
peggiorare immaginate la situazione
commerciante di Los Angeles torno a casa
stanco dopo una giornata di duro lavoro
pronto a rifocillarsi nel focolare
domestico dimenticare per la notte gli
affari riceve un telegramma da Londra
Che ordina 20.000 Barini di farina a
patto che la risposta venga immediata
venga inviata immediatamente Ecco che
allora l'uomo deve ingurgitare
velocemente la cena niente bimbi niente
coccole con la moglie perché deve
inviare velocemente il telegramma e non
perdere l'affare
da qui sparisce l'orario di lavoro
si logorano i confini vita lavoro
ovviamente in favore del lavoro
la gente diventa sempre più dipendente
dall'orologio Comincia a diventare
sempre più impellente chiedersi sempre
più spesso quand'è adesso Che ore sono
a questo punto molti di voi Penseranno
che se forse non avessimo nessun
riferimento orario tutti potremmo essere
più produttivi se James Hamlet magari
non fosse mai nato questo sarebbe un
mondo migliore ma non è così l'orologio
in quanto strumento di misurazione del
tempo ha una sua utilità
La domanda è
siete sicuri di ricordarvi qual è
perché vedete quando uno strumento non
viene creato per nessun altro motivo che
non viene usato per nessun altro motivo
tranne quello per cui è stato creato
come un martello dovete proprio
impegnarvi per sbagliare e utilizzarlo è
difficile capite cioè Siamo al
ristorante cosa pensereste nel vedere
una coppia di innamorati seduti al
tavolo che trafficano con un martello da
cantiere invece che parlare tra loro
che diavolo ci fa un martello in un
ristorante Cosa ci fate perché non
parlate
Eppure oggi è del tutto normale al
ristorante vedere qualcuno con la
versione moderna di un telegrafo
appoggiata sul tavolo mentre cena oppure
vedere qualcuno per strada con la
versione moderna di una macchina da
scrivere appoggiata sulle ginocchia
mentre guida
Allora cosa è successo sono cambiate le
regole dei contesti sociali sono
cambiati le funzioni degli strumenti No
solo che gli strumenti sono diventati
più piccoli e più leggeri quindi più
facili da usare questo ci fa riflettere
perché Quando iniziamo a utilizzare uno
strumento
solo perché è più comodo ed economico
Siamo di fronte a quello che io chiamo
fenomeno della distorsione delle
funzioni cioè dimentichiamo la funzione
originale di uno strumento e lo usiamo
motivati solo da un piccolo vantaggio
che di solito è la comodità
dimenticando e sottovalutando tutti gli
svantaggi primi fra gli altri
dispersione di tempo isolamento sociale
farci dimenticare e confondere le nostre
priorità
nel tempo abbiamo imparato a confondere
tantissime funzioni degli strumenti a
distorcere tantissime funzioni di molti
strumenti il telefono le riunioni
internet prendiamo le mail conoscete le
email non le usate Ecco nel 1929
vivevano 1,5 miliardi di persone sul
pianeta terra
queste persone si scambiavano un numero
di 20 milioni di telegrammi tra di loro
siamo come dice la slide bene 2010
eravamo sette miliardi Quindi 5 5 volte
di più e ci scambiamo un numero di mail
che è l'evoluzione del telegramma pari a
600 milioni
ma non in un anno
in 10 minuti
fanno
86.400 milioni di mele in un solo
singolo giorno
ora in soli 90 anni può essere che
l'esigenza di inviare e ricevere
messaggi sia così aumentata O forse è
solo diventato più comodo e facile
mandare messaggi Io credo fermamente
alla seconda
inviamo miliardi di messaggi in più non
perché questo ci porta più valore Ma
perché abbiamo distorto la funzione
originale dei messaggi
ora volete una un altro esempio di
distorsione delle funzioni originali e
sottolineo originali tra poco capirete
perché
pare che il 65% degli americani passi
più tempo con il pc che con il coniuge
se non è una distorsione delle funzioni
originali questa Fa riflettere
al massimo uno strumento che cosa
dobbiamo fare devono coesistere due
condizioni
la prima dobbiamo connetterci alle
funzioni originali dello strumento che
non è difficile Credetemi perché di
solito sono le stesse della sua versione
antenata cioè quella che esisteva prima
delle innovazioni tecnologiche
seconda condizione dobbiamo essere
consapevoli di cosa stiamo producendo
mentre stiamo usando quello strumento
quanto è difficile rispondere a questa
domanda Cosa state producendo ora per
uno scultore all'opera Capisco che non è
difficile ma per un impiegato per un
manager per un imprenditore per uno
studente mentre state ascoltando un Ted
Talk che cosa state producendo si
produce sempre qualcosa
molte persone quasi tutti È facilissimo
rispondere alla domanda Cosa stai
facendo
producendo è tutt'altra questione
cerchiamo Quindi se siete d'accordo di
rispondere a questa domanda cosa
produciamo nella nostra vita e nel
nostro lavoro
la parola produttività deriva
etimologicamente dalle parole fertilità
e felicità essere in uno stato di alta
produttività non la riconducibile allo
stacanovismo oppure alla ricchezza
economica ma più all'essere fertili di
valore
cioè produrre in abbondanza per sé e per
gli altri Ok Marco capitolo
15 anni di lavoro ho capito che ci sono
quattro capitali che tutte le persone
produttive puntano a creare in ogni loro
azione E immancabilmente le persone de
produttive ignorano o trascurano
completamente
questi quattro capitali sono capitali
energetico che rappresenta la nostra
energia vitale dipende dalla nostra
energia fisica mentale ed emotiva
il capitale relazionale che rappresenta
le No la qualità e la quantità delle
nostre
si capisce relazioni
il capitale economico che rappresenta la
nostra ricchezza economica sotto le sue
varie forme e il capitale esecutivo che
rappresenta ciò che sapete fare meglio
della media cioè il vostro know quello
che sapete fare in modo completo e
corretto
L'abbondanza di questi quattro capitali
è un buon indicatore della produttività
di un individuo la carenza anche solo di
uno di questi capitali è di solito un
sintomo di The produttività
quello che è Importante sottolineare che
questi capitali si sviluppano meglio uno
alla volta cercare di fare un'attività
in cui sviluppate due capitali insieme
9 volte su 10 vi porta a trascurarne
completamente Uno oppure a non
incrementarne nessuno dei due
Provate a leggere un libro mentre siete
al parco con vostro figlio
Provate a rispondere a una mail Mentre
siete un tetto Talk Provate a fare un
preventivo Mentre siete immersi in una
cena romantica due capitali che si cerca
di sviluppare nello stesso momento per
citare Un antico proverbio cinese chi
vuole rincorrere due conigli non ne
prenderà neanche
Uno
il motivo per cui capitali si sviluppano
meglio singolarmente E perché
necessitano di un diverso approccio con
l'orologio
o per meglio dire con quella che viene
definita efficienza
Giusto per essere chiari e allinearci
sono efficace se ottengo l'obiettivo che
mi sono prefissato sono efficiente se
non ho speso più del necessario in
termini di tempo energia e denaro per
ottenere l'obiettivo che mi sono
prefissato ok Finito questo il mio
consiglio è da oggi in poi di dividere
Ogni vostra attività tutte le attività
che avete in due categorie ben distinte
in funzione dell'importanza che viene
associata all'efficienza categoria
numero 1 capitele bene comprendete le
bene queste due categorie capitolo
categoria 1
attività ha risultato definito sono
quelle attività il cui valore cui il
risultato produce un valore definito di
solito raggiungibile attraverso un
protocollo o una procedura
in questa attività l'efficienza cioè
farle durare di meno è tanto importante
quanto ottenere il risultato
Sono in una riunione per fare una del
per delegare una mansione una nuova
mansione un mio collaboratore Allora
l'efficienza cioè far durare di meno la
riunione sarà tanto importante quanto
l'efficacia che è
fare in modo che la delega vada a buon
fine
poi ci sono le attività a valore
incrementale sono quelle per cui vale
l'equazione più tempo uguale più valore
più tempo di qualità investo in queste
attività e più alto sarà il valore
finale per queste attività l'efficienza
non ha nessuna rilevanza non conta nulla
perché il risultato è talmente
importante che copre tutte le spese
quando mi metto a costruire un castello
di LEGO con mia figlia Io amo i LEGO e
amo anche mia figlia è
l'efficacia Qual è il risultato sarà
costruire il miglior castello di LEGO
del condominio Oh sarà capitale
relazionale cioè
sviluppare una relazione d'amore di
fiducia nei suoi confronti
sarà molto più importante di risparmiare
qualche minuto sulla tabella di marcia
della giornata Michelangelo Ha impiegato
quattro anni a dipingere la Cappella
Sistina ora non avesse impiegati quattro
e mezzo sarebbe cambiato nulla Ma se pur
di rispettare una scadenza avesse
scarabocchiato frettolosamente gli
ultimi affreschi
eccetera d'accordo con me che sarebbe
cambiato tutto
ora queste distinzioni ci fanno
riflettere su un concetto inusuale nella
cultura moderna nella società
contemporanea cioè che la produttività
non vuol dire essere sempre efficaci e
sempre efficaci efficienti non vuol dire
ottenere sempre il massimo risultato con
il minimo sforzo
la produttività e quindi la felicità
sono il risultato di saper attribuire la
giusta importanza al controllo del tempo
nelle vostre attività
e ci sono
oltre l'orologio due modi per
controllare il tempo 1 le gli allarmi
c'è un dispositivo vi ricorda quando
finisce una certa attività due eventi e
bisogni fisiologici cioè Finisco quando
cala la luce quando ho fame quando ho
sete quando sono stanco quanto
Semplicemente ho finito il mio compito
Ecco vorrei lasciarvi con due regole
d'oro per orientarvi meglio nella
gestione del tempo e usare in modo più
funzionale l'orologio regola numero uno
eliminate ogni forma di orologio nelle
attività valore incrementale quando
siete immersi in un'attività Dove state
evolvendo una relazione dove State
creando Qualcosa di unico fatto in modo
che non ci sia un dispositivo a
ricordarvi che così Che ore sono
distraendovi
vivetele con la massima presenza
e fatevi guidare dei bisogni fisiologici
e dagli eventi
seconda regola nell'attività che
richiedono un alto livello di
concentrazione di forza di volontà usate
gli allarmi ma anche qui fate sparire
gli orologi questo eviterà di farvi
guardare l'orologio come un impulso
automatico e quindi di far diventare la
procrastinazione la perdita di tempo
come un'abitudine non importa quanto
semplici piccole possono sembrare di
queste regole vi posso garantire per
esperienza personale che abbandonare
l'orologio nelle attività veramente
importanti intendo ogni forma di
orologio e di riferimento orario può
avere un impatto fortissimo sulla vostra
vita e su quella delle persone che vi
circondano
Il mondo è pieno di storie di persone
che
distratte da un orologio dimenticano
quanto valore possono produrre
e non c'è nessuna ragione per cui tra
queste storie dovreste aggiungere la
vostra grazie
[Applauso]